you are likely already familiar with the
idea of a slope of a line if you're not
i encourage you to review it on khan
academy but all it is it's describing
the rate of change of a vertical
variable with respect to a horizontal
variable so for example here i have our
classic y-axis in the vertical direction
and x-axis in the horizontal direction
and if i wanted to figure out the slope
of this line i could pick two points say
that point and that point
i could say okay from this point to this
point what is my change in x well my
change in x would be this distance right
over here
change in x
the greek letter delta this triangle
here it's just shorthand for change so
change in x
and i could also calculate the change in
y
so
this point going up to that point our
change in y
would be
this right over here our change in y
and then we would define slope or we
have defined slope as change in y over
change in x
so slope
is equal to the rate of change of our
vertical variable over the rate of
change of our horizontal variable it's
sometimes described as rise over run
and for any line it's associated with a
slope because it has a constant rate of
change if you took any two points on
this line no matter how far apart or no
matter how close together anywhere they
sit on the line if you were to do this
calculation you would get the same slope
that's what makes it a line but what's
fascinating about calculus is we're
going to build the tools so that we can
think about the rate of change not just
of a line which we've called slope in
the past we can think about the rate of
change the instantaneous rate of change
of a curve of something whose rate of
change is possibly constantly changing
so for example
here's a curve where the rate of change
of y with respect to x is constantly
changing even if we wanted to use our
traditional tools if we said okay we can
calculate the average rate of change
let's say between this point and this
point well what would it be well the
average rate of change between this
point and this point would be the slope
of the line that connects them
so it'd be the slope of this line of the
secant line but if we pick two different
points we pick this point and this point
the average rate of change between those
points all of a sudden looks quite
different it looks like it has a higher
slope so even when we take the slopes
between two points on the line the
secant lines you can see that those
slopes are changing
but what if we wanted to ask ourselves
an even more interesting question
what is the
instantaneous rate of change at a point
so for example
how fast is y changing with respect to x
exactly at that point exactly when x is
equal to that value let's call it x1
well one way you could think about it is
what if we could draw a tangent line to
this point a line that just touches the
graph right over there and we can
calculate the slope of that line well
that should be the rate of change at
that point the instantaneous rate of
change so in this case the tangent line
might look something
like that if we know the slope of this
well then we could say that that's the
instantaneous rate of change at that
point why do i say instantaneous rate of
change well think about the video on the
sprinters the usain bolt example if we
wanted to figure out the speed of usain
bolt at a given instant well maybe this
describes his position with respect to
time if y was position and x is time
usually you would see t is time but
let's say x is time so then if we're
talking about right at this time we're
talking about the
instantaneous rate
and this idea is the central idea of
differential calculus and it's known as
a derivative
the slope of the tangent line
which you could also view as the
instantaneous
rate of change i'm putting exclamation
mark because it's so conceptually
important here
so how can we denote a derivative
one way is known as leibniz's notation
and leibniz is one of the fathers of
calculus along with isaac newton and his
notation you would denote the slope of
the tangent line as
equaling d y
over dx
now why do i like this notation because
it really comes from this idea of a
slope which is change in y over change
in x
as you'll see in future with videos one
way to think about the slope of the
tangent line is well let's calculate the
slope of secant lines let's say between
that point and that point but then let's
get even closer say that point in that
point and then let's get even closer in
that point in that point and then let's
get even closer and let's see what
happens as the change in x approaches
zero
and so using these d's instead of deltas
this was leibniz's way of saying hey
what happens if my changes in say x
become close to zero so this idea this
is known as sometimes differential
notation leibniz's notation is instead
of just changing y over change in x
super small changes in y for a
super small change in x especially as
the change in x approaches zero and as
you will see that is how we will
calculate the derivative
now there's other notations
if this curve is described as y is equal
to
f of x
the slope of the tangent line at that
point could be denoted as equaling
f
prime
of x1
so this notation it takes a little bit
of time getting used to the lagrange
notation
it's saying f prime is representing the
derivative it's telling us the slope of
the tangent line for a given point
so if you input an x into this function
into f you're getting the corresponding
y value if you input an x into f prime
you're getting the slope of the tangent
line at that point
now another notation that you'll see
less likely in a calculus class but you
might see in a physics class is the
notation
y with a dot over it so you could write
this as y
with a dot over it which also denotes
the derivative you might also see y
prime this would be more common in a
math class
now as we march forward in our calculus
adventure we will build the tools to
actually calculate these things and if
you're already familiar with limits they
will be very useful as you can imagine
because we're really going to be taking
the limit of our change in y over change
in x as our change in x approaches zero
and we're not just going to be able to
figure it out for a point we're going to
be able to figure out general equations
that describe the derivative for any
given point so be very very excited